[Music]
in 2002 stephen hawking's book the
theory of everything was published the
title suggesting that the
scientific method is so powerful but it
has omniscient potential
the first question of the debate is
can science
in principle describe everything
slavoy will start with you and then this
is a free-for-all people can
can jump and
have a free exchange
again we have to be very specific
science
we mean the modern science first galileo
and so on physics that model and then we
know
sorry what happened in the uh in the
20th
century but then
let's go to the end what interests me
are those mixed phenomena like
did you hear about
neuro theology
the idea which i think will ultimately
fail
fail to uh
artificially through simple intervention
into our brain arouse
generate religious
experiences of course this is a limited
procedure but it nonetheless interests
me what remains after this of
traditional uh of traditional
religion second thing precisely this
plasticity adaptability of religious
experiences how it can adapt incorporate
nutrients
is for me rather
a sign of its
insufficiency
like
sorry but all religions cannot be true
if you take them seriously and doesn't
this adaptability
rather not
signal in the sense that there is some
basic propensity towards religious
experience i admit this it's very
difficult to be a
eight
consequence
i would even go that was the point of my
niece for example to say that most
people even atheists at some practical
level
they
they are religious even stalinism not in
the sense that stalin was like god and
so on but you know when stalinists speak
about
objective necessity responsibility
in the view of the loss of history and
so on
they presuppose a figure of the big
other where if i repeat it so the
ultimate meaning of everything we do
will be finally
recognized
so you presuppose a kind of divine
perspective the meeting the meaning
story of everything
of everything uh will be
settled but uh you know that's my
paradoxical relationship towards
religion although i'm an atheist
you know where for me religion is at its
most interesting
when precisely it tries to adapt to
science but leads to apparently crazy
results my probably most of you know
this story which is again absolutely my
favorite one
about uh
how a friend of darvin some british
bishop whatever who was literal
christian believer had a problem he saw
that darwin is onto something clear yes
but
the bible tells him he was literally
that our universe was created a little
bit over 4 000 years ago so how to
combine this
with
with
implications of darwinism you i hope you
know what his solution was the best
theory of ideology that i know his
solution was that of course god cannot
lie he did create our world four
thousand and something years ago
but he directly created for feels like
creating reality in a
movie studio to give us a wrong
impression of openness i think that is
the best definition of ideology this
false openness creating your own
past
can
science in principle uh
it describes everything
i think
this is the standard not religious but
even modern european transcendental
philosophical argument it cannot because
it lacks this philosophical reflexivity
which shows you the conditions of your
own scientific activity i'm not a
habermassian but here hamer must made a
good point where he said yes we can
provide a perfect naturalist description
of a human being but we are doing this
as members of scientific community
following a certain procedure a certain
understanding of being
i agree with your government about
mechanism materialism and this was not
simply the result of studying reality it
could be clearly shown that this
mechanism aspect was an aprilia that
this materialist of the 18th century
brought into
reality so this type of reflection which
shows how scientific reasoning itself it
may try to explain everything but in
some sense it's unable to to fully
account for itself something a certain
scientific approach to reality and so on
must already be here
and you always already presuppose it
this circularity i think escapes
science itself at least in the sense of
modern science
the limitations of materialism are
fairly clear when it comes to
consciousness
but it's also
run into great problems in cosmology and
physics as most people know many
cosmologists now think we live in a
multiverse with billions trillions of
other unobserved universes not a shred
of evidence for them
95 percent of reality is dark matter and
dark energy we haven't got a clue what
they are they've been invented to shore
up the equations of physics so the
cosmology works but by titrating in as
much dark matter as convenient to make
the equations balance
and superstring and m theory with 10 and
11 dimensions are untestable
they predict the existence of at least
10 to the 500 other realities or
universes
so physics is a mess and many people
feel that theoretical physics is stuck i
think it's stuck
but meanwhile
the problem of consciousness and
consciousness studies is the most
glaring limitation
of materialist science
and i think that's what's so interesting
is that in response to the heart problem
many uh
philosophers of mind even if they're
atheists and materialists are now
becoming pan psychists there's been a
pan psychist turn in philosophy
saying there's some kind of
consciousness even in atoms and
molecules
if you take that seriously as i do
myself
then you have to ask well what about the
consciousness of the sun i recently
published a paper in the journal of
consciousness studies called is the sun
conscious i answer yes probably and what
about the consciousness of the galaxy of
the universe and if we get to the
consciousness of the universe then how
does that differ from pantheism and if
we get to pantheism how's that very
different from various forms of
panentheisms
we get into a realm of theological
discussion
so i feel that materialist science is
certainly very very limited and its
limitations are obvious
i think science is likely to expand to
become much more pen
psychist and
i think there are other principles in
science which are likely to be expanded
including our view of the mind
and allowing it to escape from the
confines of the brain
and so science can expand a lot further
than it has done now it's held back by
materialist dogma
but even so i think it will still be
incomplete because it will still
presuppose ourselves our minds our own
abilities to understand the universe um
which it won't explain because
the mind that's doing the understanding
can't very easily explain itself since
it's presupposed and so i think there
will always be limitations but i think
right now it's more limited than it
needs to be
so i i'll happen here
in response to the question whether
science and principle could describe
everything
um and maybe just add this
i guess
well one is that it hasn't so far um
most
reputable scientists that i'm aware of i
mean this is the the dawkins quote
actually sort of takes me by surprise
don't think that it can
um have no expectation that in any time
soon it will be able to but i think the
maybe more pressing or for me more
interesting question is would we even
want it to
and here i must say i have um a little
anecdote from richard rorty um who's
american philosopher who has this
wonderful um
little scenario that he has in a piece
that he wrote in the mid 80s called
sciences solidarity and he's very very
cheeky and i think quite funny and here
he's talking about philosophers but we
could say the same thing about
scientists so let me just do this
wordian move he's invites us to imagine
a scenario where the greatest
scientists pardon me all over the world
are convened together to come up with
the truth about the entirety of the
world
yeah they're going to describe
everything and they have their their
their many maybe days long um
conversation and then they all agree
they can agree
that um values are objective that
science is rational that truth
corresponds to reality and lo and behold
they can describe the whole universe for
us and they're just going to put it
together and hand it out you know pass
it out um in due course
we've already asked the question would
would people say
you know yay we've been saved the
scientists are going to answer
everything for us or would we recoil in
horror
not only at their hubris
but also at the utter absurdity um of of
of of of that claim and rory proposes or
supposes as do i that i think i would
hope that many uh that that those of us
sitting around the zoom room um or
listening in would be like the latter um
so
why would that even be something
desirable because again science is
something that human beings do so what
you're really saying is you're going to
hand it over to a group of human beings
to then adjudicate what the absolute
truths of our world are and i think that
would be um
boring at least
um and terrifying at at worst so um
that's that's my thought on that that
question
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you